[Musique]
pouy
qu'est ce que vous faites habillée comme
ça on va la noce ans marie pas bon non
pas toi moi je me marie à moi j'suis
garçons d'honneur et pourquoi tu es
habillée comme ça toi j'étais un petit
bistrot oui c'est content de tourner
avec nous très contente parce que nous
on est très contentes on avait trop fier
de tourner avec moi donc c'est un
honneur mais voilà tu fais des raccords
après oui après girac or c'est des
raccords prologue mario wii et petits
jouent toujours cyrano oui mais j'ai
abandonné le costume est maintenant je
joue à bobines ou la parodie du symat
est un paradis décida we made it idée
très bien et bien je vous de guide dans
cyrano césure alors et à face et bien je
vais très bien bon alors voilà longtemps
que je travaille à tous dès maintenant
afin de comédie musicale à l'alhambra v
que jean paul a racheté l'alhambra je
t'avais dit pas le dr fall et cassel qui
produit le spectacle et à la
chorégraphie et puis madame bretons
de la caisse maintenant voilà c'est tout
nos projets sont annoncés d'une comédie
musicale en couleurs oui et une musique
américaine et j'ai un peu briani chante
non plus parce que je me suis tellement
gueuler que je veux dire des poèmes
claude rich dans sera la première à
trophées et jean-paul l'on fasse un
numéro de gala de l'union qui a
tellement plu oui merci
et puis voilà voilà je veux pas dire son
nom même nom n'avait été trouvé voilà
vous laisser
[Musique]